hi guys it's lottie i'm beauty editor
here at glam uk and today i'm with the
amazing chris appleton color wow's
global ambassador what a title i know
right wow
and today we're going to be teaching you
how to get this glass hair look in our
glass hair tutorial so i feel like glass
hair is like a huge deal at the moment i
mean probably you guys are more know it
on kim kardashian and we've kind of
played with it on all different lengths
from like super long to like the
futuristic kind of bob vibe so it's kind
of a combination of using the right
product and we're going to add a couple
of hair extensions to give you that real
oh yeah
okay cool first of all we're going to
prep the hair so your hair's been washed
which is great so this product is called
dreamcoat so this is a lot about this
it's a very special product right it's
going to transform the texture of your
hair into amazingly glass-like shiny
hair the one thing you need to do is
make sure you really saturate the hair
in it so make sure each strand of hair
gets the same treatment so i'm just
combing that first just evenly saturated
so we're going to stretch the hair out
now i'm just going to use a large
bristle brush and we're basically just
going to dry the products in the hair
okay guys so when you get to the top
section you want to make sure you get a
really super clean middle part so just
use a tail comb like so because that
will give you that super like futuristic
perfect looking glass-like hair you know
so if i was doing this at home could i
just roughly blow dry it and then run
the straighteners through it's a really
good point actually for you guys at home
if you are doing this i know it almost
seems a bit more work blow drying the
hair but honestly relying on the
stroking lines won't cut it you want to
make sure you use the dream coat on the
wet hair but then you do need to dry it
in if you're at home you can use like a
regular paddle brush paddle brush is
pretty easy to use right you know just a
flat brush just get it through and just
get it dry if you do just spend a second
blow drying the mid lamps and ends like
you get that much more shiny glossy
finish and see how the hair moves and it
has that swish it feels so nice in my
face last hair doesn't have to just be
straight so for example kim's met ball
lock when she had like that wave it was
like wave when we pulled the front off
it was like halfway down it was wavy and
bouncy but it was like it was like
immaculate you'll see here if we had to
decide how it parts a little bit here
where it's a little bit thinner so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to show you
how to fill this section out which is
what gives you that real kind of
futuristic flawless like glass
i guess it's like a dream bob you know
this is like the dream bob yeah so this
is really easy to use we're gonna use
some hair extensions i just pulled them
out my back pocket like it's a magic
trick
so when we're doing it instead of taking
sections that are square if we take
sections that are square and flat the
hair is just gonna fall away from the
face so we're gonna take sections on a
diagonal so the hair falls into the face
so we're going to spray some spray
on the roots and if you want to as well
you can just get the hair dryer in there
and you can just flatten that down
[Music]
and then you want to measure
the width of hair that you want and
we'll just cut that away
well it's just going to place it in at
the top here
sit it nice and flat to the head and
then we just use a hair dryer to dry it
so if you see that hair now see that's
glass hair that immaculate shiny glossy
hair and we'll just cut these thin ends
off
[Music]
so we're just finishing off by running
the irons over the top just to seal
everything in
so i'm just literally spraying a bit of
hairspray on my hands just to keep all
this front section together i'm using my
hands rather than a brush and then a
nice little tip as well is to spray the
top section with hair spray and just
flatten down those flyaways okay so
there you have it glass hair how does it
feel everyone feels amazing you look
amazing so much chris you're welcome i
love doing it on you i hope you picked
up some too yeah i absolutely did and
you guys at home as well um like i say
kind of interpret how you feel thank you
so much for watching and if you want to
see more videos just like this head over
to glamour uk's youtube channel and
don't forget to follow us on all our
social channels